[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thank you for
listening today i always say it thanks
for tuning in without you where are we
ryan
god
god i don't know
uh the infinite space between us and god
yeah i think that's where we are we need
you we love you we love that you tune in
i hope you're having a glorious week i
hope you hopefully you're taking care of
yourself
doing something productive
having a little purpose in your life
yeah you know
um
my uh good buddy preston christensen
he's 16 years old he has terminal cancer
and i love the kid and uh
going to visit him
and his family and uh
it's tough man you see a little kid so
bright so cheerful so lovable so smart
and creative and uh it just sucks man
but he's so strong it's like i gotta
wish i was half as strong as this guy
but i want to give a shout out to him
he's a he's a beautiful beautiful soul
and uh
we probably have to play one of his
songs he has a song that he's never
really sang other than playing a little
guitar but uh he recorded a song
so uh
actually
i have to edit this um is it streamable
no it was just he did a cover of a
of a uh
blake shelton song oh cool
he's 16 he's never been in a recording
studio before and
he did this at home or do this in the
studio no studio but he just sang they
already had the music
the ready it's friday night you should
be out on the town
didn't think you'd be sitting at home
all alone like me nothing on tv
[Music]
i'm so proud of them
listen to this chorus here
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway
big shout out to preston he's a killer
he's a he's a man of many talents and i
love him and i love michelle and chris
and the family
thinking about you guys and uh you know
hey
i'm thinking positively that's what i'm
doing thinking positively uh great guest
today
david dost mulchin if you don't know him
you should great story
he's polka dot man in the
suicide squad movie he's he's in dune
he's uh he's always working now and he
is such an amazing person ant-man
ant-man the crazy guy from dark knight
yep that's a very famous scene done he's
just done a lot of great stuff and he's
going to get big and big i see his
instagram just exploding and after a
suicide squad so i love having him in a
podcast we're going to get right into
that but uh first thank you for joining
me uh this last saturday on stage it we
had two shows we had my buddy tom lally
who's in left on laurel with me and he
joined sunspin and we sang some old left
on laurel songs and it was a blast also
i'll be in detroit with tom welling and
we'll do smallville nights on december
15th that weekend saturday and sunday so
make sure you get tickets
for the detroit con
and uh also if you want to get back to
the podcast
some people really support the podcast
uh so many great patrons but go to
patreon.com inside of you and join
patron and um
so many great friendships have have
have what have
spawned materialize materialized there
we go come to be uh our handles are at
inside of you podcast on the instagram
and facebook and at insideapod on the
twitter i hope you'll continue to
support us and uh listen to the podcast
there's so many podcasts out there but
hopefully every week you're listening to
this one at least once or twice and
telling all your friends please do we're
also available on youtube if you want to
watch it which is always fun but right
now let's get into my dear friend um
great great guy david mulchin it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
dude it's great to see you where are you
i'm in
malta the beautiful island country of
malta which is about
i don't know 100 miles maybe not even 50
miles south of sicily um so we're in the
middle of the mediterranean and i'm on
my last
leg
of a
very long
and exhausting shoot so it's so nice to
see you this is like you're the glimmer
of light at the end of the tunnel for me
like i'm coming home
yes yes well we all miss you uh what are
you shooting
um uh it's a film called the last voyage
of the demeter and it's um
interesting story it is uh lifted from a
chapter from bram stoker's dracula and
it's actually a story that because i
write as well and it's a story i've
always wanted to write into a
a screenplay it's a fascinating tale it
reminds me of um kind of like alien
except set on a schooner in 1897 so it's
the boat that
travels from bulgaria to london and the
crew doesn't realize that in the hold is
the prince of darkness himself dracula
and all of his belongings because he's
moving himself to carthage carfax abbey
and london so the whole film takes place
on this ship uh from beginning to end
and um wow we've been living we've been
living the life of it feels like i've
been at sea for four and a half months
man how often how many crew members got
sick
oh you know what um we did a sailing
thing but most of the time we're on a
controlled there are um we're we're in
this giant tank
on the edge of the sea
so and it's like an infinity pool like
optical illusion so i don't know because
if someone got sick they weren't stuck
with us they could just hop off and get
get get away but i i saw at least
four or five people and we're on um what
do you call a you know the things that
make something shake what is that right
always like
you know doing this number and right
effects machines or whatever that just
kind of turned the boat and things like
that
wow and you and you wrote this
no i i didn't sorry i didn't i
i always wanted to always wanted to
write this
then
um
about two years ago i pitched the idea
um to
a friend who's an exec who said there's
already a script and it's amazing and
it's being made by amblin
and then i just did everything i could
to get an audition for the film which i
did and miraculously i got cast so are
you serious what are the odds of that
you want to do something you find out
there's a script you get an audition and
you get the part
i went i hadn't gone this hard and heavy
after something in
i feel like since maybe like theater day
like i
chased this thing fought for this thing
i put together the best t because this
is covid times you know i had to tape
this audition with my lovely
understanding and patient wife who
helped me is three massive setups for
the audition big dialect work it's a
period piece
it's a character that's very much
not like anything i've had the privilege
of doing before he he moves differently
than i've ever moved he speaks
differently than i've ever spoken and so
it was like
i i almost built a whole character just
for the i mean i did i thought i built a
whole role for just the audition
and when when i sent it off
i
honestly had a lot of peace because i
said there's
just no way there's just no way and then
lo and behold like a few weeks later
well what what did you do though like
when you said like your yourself what we
do here if you're listening you don't
understand the process is a lot of times
you self tape especially with covid you
put yourself on tape now
your background a lot of people would
just use the background you have a hotel
room or wherever you're staying and
they'll just read the scene and
hopefully they get cast but you did more
than that
yeah yeah yeah so we were
we were renting a house in burbank
because there was some um emergency
construction that we were having to do
at our house and so we were renting this
house um and the bedroom for some reason
they had
a
these drawstring curtains i never
figured out what they were for on the in
not for the windows like
going over the closet or going over one
of the walls i don't know but
there's three scenes that they sent me
um each one was
three to five pages
like 12 pages of scene work and the
first scene
is my character who is um
the first mate of this ship he's
trying to round up a crew and it's a
very
loud
you know
abrasive kind of scene then there's a
very confrontational
scene which takes place in the hold of
the boat um
which i wanted to do a completely
different setup so i did that against
like a big wooden um
you know dresser it looked like i was
maybe there was some wood maybe it felt
like a boat and then for the last one it
was a really emotional scene and we
framed the camera like as close as
probably i am here with you
and um
and i just you know you got to just
shoot for the [ __ ]
sorry you could say dude we f all the
time on this show okay you gotta shoot
for the [ __ ] fence you gotta go you
gotta swing
and um
i reached out the character i play is
polish so i reached out to um
my friend who is a big and he's a
linguist and he's connected to people
all over the language community because
i didn't want to go to a dialect coach i
wanted to actually
work with a polish speaker to get some
specific nuance
and and when when that wonderful person
um agreed to work with me for the
audition i said if i book this i'm going
to hire you as my dialect coach i put it
out in the universe and i booked it and
then i hired them to be my dialect coach
and they've become a good friend do they
come out with you or they have they just
they live in poland and they um we did
all of our work through zoom but they
are they have a background in theater
and they love
they just they never worked
professionally as a dialect coach
especially for a movie are you kidding
and they were like
this is so cool so
um we had them down to because we were
shooting in berlin for the first few
months so they came down to berlin and
they
uh got to come to
because of cobit again it's like so
ridiculous like they can't come within
400 feet of whatever but they got to at
least go to we shot them the berlin
stuff at babelsberg studios which anyone
watching look it up it's one of the most
historic
um film studios in the world i want to
say it's the oldest uh i could be wrong
i have my little book on 100 facts about
babblesberg but it's a
really amazing place where they filmed
um
metropolis fritz lang's metropolis they
filmed um
tons of
you know marlena dietrich stuff and um
so anyway yeah they came and hung out
and you really do the work like i i hear
a lot of actors and a lot of times we'll
just you know we'll just do it whatever
but you really dive into something and
especially an audition that you don't
know you're gonna get you're probably
thinking i probably won't get it i don't
know what your mindset is but to work so
hard on 15 pages of dialogue and
different setups and
working with a dialects coach i mean
that's extreme to try and get a role but
you think that that's the way you get
roles that's what you're saying
that works for me and i think this is
everyone's journey as you know is so
specific to the individual it's so
it's so weird what we do and the whole
path is so strange and elusive and it
feels so much like the lottery so often
so the the things that are within my
control
which i can have some say so in
is my energy and where i'm gonna put the
energy and i when it comes to something
that i want to go after
um
like doggedly like there's something
that i i just i i know
i
i will i will focus the energy on that
and possibly maybe not do
you know five or six auditions in a
month but maybe just focus on that one
or that two thing but give it all i've
got which is really tricky and it's
risky and it takes a lot of um
a lot of overcoming my fear because you
second-guess yourself a lot and you go
oh maybe i would have done better
maybe that other one would have been
easier maybe they'll level it up but you
just
i try to make really you know and this
like i said this was a story that
when i first read dracula
uh 20 years ago probably i i've read the
book
numerous times since i always said rosie
like
what a story i mean it's it's lit it's
it's like alien at sea in the 1800s you
know it's like
it's so scary and i think that um
the guy who's directing it his name is
andre overdoll he made a
film called troll hunter oh my god
guys if you have not seen troll hunter
it is
awesome
it's amazing
oh god dude he's such a visionary
he did the autopsy of jane doe yeah i
loved he did um
scary stories to tell in the dark which
i went and saw when i was in it
by myself in a movie theater i loved it
but he is
yeah and and by the way just saying
going along with
the
the audition tape
i wrote a letter
to the director um
telling him not only my you know passion
for the material but um
you know that i'm that how much i loved
trollhunter and um also i don't know if
you know this about me but when i was in
college i went to the theater school
depaul which is where shawn gone which
is where michael rooker which is where
judy greer a bunch of our friends went
but um
when i was there i was on a scholarship
for academics but i didn't have any
money to pay for my housing so i had to
take a break from school and i went to
alaska and lived as a fisherman on a
boat for a year and then i did it
several times after and being
at sea is um
something i always thought was going to
be part of my my life and then obviously
acting became
my my and you told him this you told him
this i did i said i've lived on a boat i
think i could offer some
insights i
um
wow
i think you're amazing and i you know
and i of course tried to be as gracious
as possible like obviously you know um
[Music]
i cheer for this film no matter what
whether i'm involved or not i know
you're gonna make an awesome movie and
um
and then i got the call
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy this is working i don't
know how many people have come up to me
ryan at convention saying i tried better
help it's really saving my life it's
really helping me one of those people is
helping is ryan it's helping me it's a
helpful service and you guys in the name
help help better help better help and
did you get a new therapist uh i did um
yeah just uh just recently right because
uh ryan had a therapist and so he wanted
another therapist and so that's what
happened it's so easy better help online
therapy really has done a great job and
i really appreciate having them on the
sponsor as a sponsor uh
they're just so fitting that's what we
do here we talk about a lot of things
depression anxiety look whether you're
struggling with grief relationships or
stress or you're having trouble sleeping
or meeting goals online therapy
might be for you
better help us secure online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with a licensed
professional therapist betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own accredited therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
and you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room therapists
have a broad range of expertise which
may not be available in your area the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
it's really
amazing and easy and better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if you
need like ryan it's also more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available i'm telling
you
offline therapy is so much more
expensive coming from someone who has
gone through a lot of therapy i'm
telling you this is the way to go it's
easy visit
betterhelp.com
inside and join the over 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional insider is
sponsored by better help and our
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside better help online
therapy try it folks inside of you is
brought to you by m1 finance you know
there's a reason they call m1 finance
the finance super app
this all-in-one app makes it easy as pie
to invest borrow and spend exactly how
you want
build a portfolio of stocks or etfs in
minutes with their intuitive pies
interface or use a pre-build expert pie
that invests according to your goals
investing involves risk an m1 helps you
invest according to your risk tolerance
borrow against your portfolio with some
of the lowest rates in the market then
use it however you want
keep in mind borrowing increases your
risk and rates may vary or stash your
cash in their free digital checking
account it's fast it's easy and it saves
you tons of time and time
is money switch to a sleeker easier and
better way to manage your money plus get
a thirty dollar bonus to your m1 invest
account when you get approved and fund
it with one thousand dollars within your
first 14 days just go to m1finance.com
for more info
that's m the number one
finance.com
terms and conditions apply inside of you
is brought to you by helix sleep i don't
know about you but if i have a crappy
bed or if i don't sleep
i'm effed do you understand i'm left
everybody is yeah no i get it do you
have a good dad i have an okay bed well
you need to get a better bet i probably
do helix sleep maybe helix will hook us
up with the mattress for you i mean i
wouldn't say no i you know i look the
it's extremely comfortable these beds
and i i know from back surgeries from
neck surgeries from that having a
comfortable bed is the most important
thing you could possibly do it's how you
you start every day and if you're
feeling like crap well
crap
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep everybody's unique and
helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot and even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i have the medium i have the
medium mattress because you know uh it's
like the porridge you don't want too hot
you don't want too cold you don't want
too hard you don't want too soft uh look
i took the helix quiz i was a medium it
worked out for me it's so easy you take
this little quiz and they really get to
know you and what you like and and it
just helps out for the whole usually you
buy a mattress you don't know what
you're getting i think with helix sleep
you do it's been awesome getting
messages from so many of you who also
found the helix mattress of your dreams
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again just go to
helixsleep.com
inside h-e-l-i-x sleep.com inside you
take their two-minute quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life and they have a 10
year warranty you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free folks they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattresses order well let me say that
again i almost made it through
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
inside that's
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
did you have did was it more than that
one audition or was that it was that
enough or you know that was it
that was it and so
to give your
um
your viewers a little context too i
have been without
um
the
benefit of representation either
management or agent for
it was about four four years when
i booked this job it had been since the
end of 2016. wait a minute you represent
yourself i did i did and then just in
the last month i've actually found a
partnership that i really like for
management but i did represent myself i
have a great attorney who handles my
um
you know contract negotiations and he is
when i land the job then i pass
everything over to him but i have been
kind of hunting and chasing so with this
particular job i found out who was
casting it i reached out to them
directly and sent my materials over and
then they said you know there's really
nothing for you in this film um
but
you know and that was all i heard and
then about two weeks later
i um i have a mutual
um contact with the director
i had said please you know let andre
know if there's anything i could do and
and the friend said he said you're a
fantastic actor there's nothing for you
in this fight
and then i said okay i tried i did my
best
another week later i got an email from
the casting director saying
we know this is not
your normal wheelhouse but
if you want to take a stab at this
character
you know we'd love to see what what you
would do with it and again i read it and
i was like holy crap i've never
done anything like this
in my career this character is so
um
i understand him but yet i've never had
the opportunity to get to bring someone
like him to life and so
i i threw myself into it i sent that
audition tape the letter and everything
to casting
about a month went by
and at that point i was starting to
look at okay what's my next
passionate thing you know is there is
there something else out there that i
really want to fight for or go after and
i wasn't
nothing was definitely coming in my in
my
whatever radius and i just
i sent an email to the casting director
and i said just checking in and i wrote
back and they said actually the director
really loved your
material but um
we are
we're still a ways away from making a
decision
well a
tv show a very cool seeming tv show uh
emailed me uh and said you know we are
our producers and director interested in
having you be a part of this show
um and i was like oh that's amazing
thank you
and i immediately went back to the
casino return i said
this offer is coming in now to go and be
i'd be out i'll be out of the touch for
like five months so i just want to make
sure
you know and they wrote back
thank you but there's no way we can't
make a decision for i like the i like
the uh
sort of like the way your mind works how
you did that it was kind of a
manipulation in a in a good way like hey
i just got hired for something i really
want to do this project are you sure
you're but okay so go ahead this is this
is good and and then friday morning i
got up i was in the shower i had a phone
call ringing from a
310 beverly hills
um
number
and i answered it and it was the
business affairs office from amblin
entertainment calling to say they wanted
to start contract negotiations on um the
movie holy [ __ ] i was butt naked and i
ran out of the shower and i
grabbed eve and um
yeah
my god
the work by the way can i hear it or i
mean i know most actors don't want to do
this but can i hear a polish accent just
a little
uh
here is being about polish what's
different with because
if you've seen any of some of the recent
years work i've been doing with um
like eastern european
characters there's
i've definitely done russian in this in
several roles and i've done um
actually
uh
like a
it was it was because the character was
kind of disguising himself but like a
very blanket eastern european
um and that's good so with polish one of
the things that's
yeah that i found to be quite different
was um some of the rounding of the
vowels um and
even the way like if you're thinking
about something you and i might go um
you know you're when you're in character
and you're trying to like
communicate that like
you're considering something there's
these little minutiae details that i was
so grateful to have han uh my my friend
my my my friend who dialect coached me
um
because i'd be like practicing a line
and be like
uh and they would be like no no no we
don't do that
we say
hey
i want to learn like give me a set and
see if i can do it go ahead
um okay um
um
how about this is a simple one pull you
bastard's pull
he's just saying pull you bastards pull
pull you bastards pull
you bastards and roll down
come on man join the boat join the boat
oh man that's it's a cool cast too
because it's got um
i'm the only polish character there's a
russian character there's a norwegian
character there's and several english
characters
two irish characters i want to see this
this sounds so cool what's it called
again so we could look out for i don't
know when it's gonna come out because
you're just still filming it what's it
called some people put it on the radar
called last voyage of the demeter uh
although
who knows what it'll be when it comes
out a year from now you know
it might be called like
vampire boat who knows
or it could be called dracula's journey
or the prince's journey
the ss dracula yes it's dracula
i am
[Music]
i have it on my poster because he signed
it to me i have crossed oceans
of time to find you
didn't you love him in that
he's so great he's so great and
everything but dracula coppola's dracula
is like go-to for me and there is if you
go back and watch the movie there's a
little snippet where you see the boat
come into port in london you see a wolf
jump off of
the deck that's
dracula um and that that was
so this movie is about that whole
journey of that boat because in the book
the boat comes to port and there's
nobody on board except for
the
captain who's lashed to the wheel and um
so you got to see what happens wait a
minute are you saying that the polish
guy dies
i just became a jew
my character was too jewish though never
say that i
no i am
i look at every movie as if i'm the
hero of the movie so my character never
my characters never die you know what's
funny is that you know i was talking to
my engineer ryan ryan say hi hi hi ryan
um and you can't see ryan but you should
he's a very handsome man um but you know
i was like you know if you say david
dos mulchin
a lot of people wouldn't know who you
were talking about if you said michael
rosen a lot of people wouldn't know what
you were talking about if they saw your
face though that's what he said he goes
when you see his face he's like oh i've
seen him i've seen him in a lot of
things and you're kind of like that guy
who's done a lot of great work but like
this character actor
and then
you start to dissect it and you're like
okay and
how old are you
uh 45
45 wow you don't look 45 you look
younger i'm not hitting on you thank you
yes it's all the evian skin cream
um
but a movie comes along like suicide
squad
and and we'll get into that
but like i look online and there's a
mcfarland figure of younow do you know
that
and it looks like you
i don't have any doll that looks like me
i mean you know you've made it when
mcfarland makes a doll of you
i mean it's it's it's a huge thing
because you've been doing all these
characters you're a writer you're a
director you've been through it all and
at 45
you land a role and i noticed this
because i kept checking because i'm
weird that your instagram just kept
going up and up it was like 120 140 160
200 220 240 like all these people are
following you and your your imd
pro meter number was just
going down and down and down and down's
good because the lower numbers is and
i'm like
good for [ __ ] dave das mulchin
i mean how do you feel right now we're
going to get in this because i want to
go back in time a little bit because but
um how are you feeling about all this
thank you for asking thank you for the
compliments i love you you know i'm a
huge fan of your work and i've been a
fan of your work since long before i
actually met you
in person on the back porch at james
gunn's house i've been a fan of yours
for a very long time so that's very nice
and touches my heart thank you very much
um i
two things
the first
is i have been in a bubble for since
june i was in berlin with my family
and then to malta come you know
beginning of um august and
in both of those bubbles we are not only
in a coveted bubble for production but
also the bubble of like my reality has
been being on this boat fighting dracula
or being with my family and
completely out of touch with everything
that's going on in the rest of my life
including you know family back home and
my things happening with my career back
home and so my kind of
context and connection to all of this
has been through
social media yeah and like texts and
my phone and so that has been
weird but nice people have been very
nice and thank god um people have been
very supportive of some of the stuff
recently that's you know blown up but um
the other thing and i'm glad and i hope
we could talk about this today because i
know you're not going to shy away from
talking about um
you know the stuff that is a little more
you know awkward or uncomfortable and
i'm i've been
i've been definitely below my baseline
airing towards the depressive because i
i could go down to deep depression and i
can go way up into you know high anxiety
and and manic modes and so finding my
baseline is kind of
part of my daily
journey if you will it's my lifelong
journey just being at peace and serene
with like that baseline
being
i'm struggling with
the fact that i feel so grateful that
like you're saying like my
followers
all of a sudden doubled and tripled and
quadrupled and people were being so
gracious and kind and um
neat new professional opportunities were
kind of flowering and lots of exciting
wonderful neat things happening um
and yet
my family had to leave and go back to
the u.s about a month ago and that's
really hard for me they are a big part
of my um
not only my support system but kind of
just
probably in an unhealthy way i am i am
insanely dependent upon even the kids
for a lot of my um
settling and baselining
and i need to work on that because i am
a grown adult and i should be able to do
that without you know
leaning on others but they they are
they're a big part of that and um
and i faced some really difficult
moments in the course of making this
film that i'm working on that made me
feel
dark and those were both creative
moments and also
just production moments to be quite
frank and someday we'll have coffee and
download you on all of it but it's just
needless to say you know sometimes this
business can really
make you really hurt and um
and so all these wonderful things are
happening and and then at night i'm
laying there feeling
really blue and dark and i've been
wrestling with this kind of a sense of
guilt over
not just being like
so happy all the time that like
james's movie turned out so awesome and
people loved it and you know polka dot
man's so cool and the doing stuff looks
so cool and
uh so many neat things are happening and
so
that
i've been wrestling to be honest lately
in other words you're wrestling with the
fact that you have so much to be
grateful for but you feel so down which
is making you upset that you're feeling
so down about all the good that's
happening around you and you quite can't
quite
understand it or wrap your head around
it but maybe is it something that you've
dealt with your whole life
where you know you have ups but you're
still feeling down you i mean this this
isn't something that's just happened on
this movie set
absolutely not and um
i've definitely been
it's been
some insanely challenging you know um
things and just some chemical things i'm
sure you know just my brain naturally
some reaction to i think the
overwhelming
sense that a lot of people were like
looking at you you know that that's a
weird thing when you're in a tv show or
when you're in a movie and all of a
sudden you realize how many people are
just like looking at you and you become
con you you can become like grossly
um
self-conscious i mean i'm sure you i'm
sure all of us experience that as actors
and um
so
i
am
as we speak
doing the work like
getting up early trying my best to make
sure i get out of bed when i don't have
to even though i would be tempted to
stay in it for too long trying to eat
well trying to do my yoga trying to do
my meditations uh doing my therapy um
and i guess
i just always look at these public
conversations
as like an opportunity to hopefully if
anybody's listening that seems like my
god i have a
beautiful partner i have a job that i
love i have things that i love and yet i
still feel
like i've got the blues what's wrong
with me the answer is nothing nothing's
wrong with you you're this is just an
unfortunate paradox of you know the
human psyche sometimes and i think um
i just happen to be in it so that's a
you were not you did not ask for that no
i i welcome you know that i welcome that
on this show especially with people
listening because i think everybody just
assumes that we all are happy and we
should be grateful and and we are but
there's there's a thing called mental
illness there's a thing called
depression there's a thing called
anxiety there's a thing that a lot of us
get and a lot of my guests that are big
stars
and they they get it and it's it's sort
of
we've got to sort of break the norm of
of you know what's you know supposed you
know we're not supposed to be depressed
of course we are we're [ __ ] human
beings this is just life
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by geico
our good friends at geico we've talked
about this folks if you know if you want
groceries you get instacart right or
whatever you get somebody who delivers
something to you
so you don't have to leave the house
that's me a lot of us don't want to be
inconvenienced well geico has a
similarity whether you rent or own your
home
it's hard work and you know what's easy
bundling policies with geico geico makes
it so easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around the
house so you just need to do this you
just need to go to geico.com you get a
quote and see how much you could save
it's geico easy visit
geico.com today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by keeps
listen if you're going bald you want to
hear this because i have a lot of
friends who are balding and i've told
them about keeps and they are doing it
and let me tell you this stuff works uh
you know i'm gonna get into this two out
of three men will experience some form
of hair loss by the time they're 35.
that includes me and ryan here
uh yeah more than 50 million men in the
u.s suffer from male pattern baldness
and there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
guess what
keeps offers both so if you're still
listening and you're still you know
saying i don't know what to do
you should try this you should try it
because uh it's fda approved and there's
only two of them that are fda approved
and
well i'm telling you right now it seems
to work for many many people keeps
offers a simple stress-free way to keep
your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home you
know i don't like to leave my home
ryan i don't like leaving my home either
yeah i don't like it low cost treatments
start at just 10 dollars per month and
keeps offers generic versions discrete
packaging and proven results keeps has
more five-star reviews than any of its
competitors prevention is key folks
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast and if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss it's easy you go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash inside of you to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's keeps k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
inside of you to get your first month
free k-e-e-p-s dot com slash inside of
you
and but you've been dealing with this
your whole life i mean you you know we
could go back to
and i didn't know this until recently
but you're so open about it that you
know you had a you had a heroin
addiction
i mean and you how how old were you when
this happened
i first started using um when i was
around 18
um and
that evolved into full-time usage by
uh i mean 18 was like an experimenting
and experimenting with all different
kinds of opiates but then i started
using full-time um
from 21
20 21 to
uh
which is when i got clean man now i got
to do the math but yeah i want to say 26
or 27
um wow that's a long time because most
of the time you hear if you do heroin
once you're gonna die because you're
gonna because you're gonna you know i am
so
lucky and i i use that word delicately
because yes i did work hard yes i got
the support of an amazing recovery
support group and you know i had family
that even though they had to like write
me off and tough not write me off they
had to cut me off and tough love me and
like not pick up the phone they never
gave up on me if that makes sense you
know i think in recovery it's so
tempting to like let the person crash on
your couch let the person borrow 50
bucks let the person get a new phone
they had to cut that [ __ ] out but they
always said we're here
we love you blah blah and friends too
but so
but luck
it i do feel this immense
and that's one of the things that helps
me on this journey of battling my blues
is every day taking an inventory of
things that i'm grateful for and i have
so much to be grateful for not least of
which is the fact that i'm just alive
that i didn't end up in prison that i
didn't end up dead um
and
i'm here so it's uh it's nothing short
of a miracle and um
so you say your gratitude's every day
you you say your gratitude's in the
morning i do my best i fail sometimes
but i when i'm when i'm pissed off and
feeling resentful um sometimes i'm like
[ __ ]
why blah blah blah you know and then
take some great breathing if you can
just
give five minutes to shift the way
you're breathing and the way your body's
like
contacting space it always helps again
anybody watching like it sounds so
ridiculous in new age like
if you can give yourself a timeout and
just take five minutes to change the way
you're breathing the way your brain is
getting its oxygen everything
then i can go over and be like
oh my god
eve married me
for the rest of my life
she [ __ ] married me like that's
gratitude forever that's an endless
fountain of [ __ ] gratitude um i have
beautiful kids i have incredible friends
i have
i'm clean and sober you know
miraculously for another day i'll never
um wave a victory flag or say that i've
defeated
the monster that is addiction i believe
that you know it lives
around always kind of waiting you know
and yeah that's just a good metaphor for
me to keep it in check you know i i um
and it's one of the reasons why i used
to [ __ ] around a lot back when i first
started getting clean and i'd be like
i was so resentful
that like i could hang out with people i
really dug and they could just put away
three glasses of wine and then they'd
walk away and they'd maybe drink next
week i'd be around people who could
smoke pot you know
for me
my disease it like
it just
it never worked every time i would just
pick up the one thing it would just
ultimately spiral really fast and lead
back to me copying and so i uh you can
never have one drink or one smoke it'd
be like you'd have to i just don't i
don't see the point in it's been 19
years now rosie 19 years congratulations
man don't
see
the point
in
spinning that roulette wheel you know
and like
why would i i just uh but that's that's
like i say i will never be like
i've got that because i feel
i bet the house that i could drink a
glass of wine tonight and not use
tomorrow i would bet the house am i
going to take that risk though am i
going to make that bet thought no dude
because
it just it would it
makes no sense
because then it probably starts i did it
then i could do it again and i could do
it again until you really [ __ ] up and
you go down that hole
yeah and i was also treating
um undiagnosed
you know
mental issues that thankfully as i got
into recovery
and i came up against a lot of um
[Music]
you know conflict in the recovery
community and anybody uh who who is who
has been who has experienced the
recovery community or anyone who's ever
been privy to it knows that there's
as much inner
um
infighting and different opinions about
how things work as there are in like
religious religions you know what i mean
it's like it's so crazy and there are
people that are where like
taking psychiatric medications was some
form of you know drug use and i was like
tough [ __ ] i'm taking
i i work with a great psychiatrist and i
found a medication that worked
incredibly well for me after you know a
lot of work and um
that's a part of my journey as well you
know um so
yeah that's the only uh that my allergy
medicine i take something for
cholesterol uh some vitamins some fish
oils um some proteins those are the only
things i'm ingesting do you think that
you were like you know
were there reasons sometimes people just
get into something like you know drugs
but was there a depression then was
there
some sort of imbalance before that kind
of prompted you to get into that
for certain and i think um i've always
wanted to talk to you about your
experience considering you know
what you did with impastor like the how
much research or digging you did into
the religious world or where that you
know affected you personally or if you
had any experience with that i was
raised very religiously
to the point that when i started
exhibiting um suicidal ideation and
depressive behavior at a pretty young
age prepubescent like 10 11 i was um
you know
i had my first like full-on planned
suicide and um
i was treated
with
um
religious counseling like christian
counseling where you know you sit with
the guy and he tells you that you're you
know feeling anxiety because you've been
whacking off and he gives you some
scriptures to
read and that's your
that's your treatment and um
god love my parents they just didn't
know better i'm not blaming them but i
uh
i think then when i first got my
my hands around a budweiser bottle
and i felt that sweet sweet
elixir hit my lips and i was like oh
i
feel like kind of normal and then it was
like what else could make me feel normal
and then it was just the quest you know
wow
i mean so so at an early age you were
already getting these suicidal thoughts
you already knew something was not quite
right and your parents didn't know how
to help you so it just kind of uh you
went into a tailspin i guess eventually
right yeah and they couldn't control it
i was
i was what you call high functioning in
the sense that like i was definitely uh
scholastically you know above average
throughout high school i participated in
uh extracurricular activities i i loved
theater in the arts i also loved sport
and i loved um
having a good time obviously but you
know i was um
it was a dangerous concoction because i
was very good at i mean
i was a good actor
i was good at pretending like you know i
was
i was okay yeah
how did you get off it what was the
final because you used to have to hit i
guess you have to hit rock bottom before
something happens right and they're
homeless i was homeless um
anybody who is checking out this
conversation and and you know wants to i
i wrote and acted
in a film that my dear friend colin
animals
animals yes and if you guys ever get a
chance to check it out it's not my bio
pic but it is definitely
inspired by the reality and in the film
you know a guy and his girlfriend live
in their car and i did i lived in a car
for quite a while i was stealing um
anything i could to resell to support my
habit i was
um
i it was it was terrible man i was um
thoroughly ashamed of myself as soon as
i would start to get sick or come down
and withdrawal the shame and the guilt
of what i had done with my life and all
this opportunity having been a
privileged white kid from kansas city
who had gotten to go study acting at
this amazing school was
spending his
throwing his life away on like smack i
was like i was so ashamed and so
embarrassed and i
the voices that were like
you're no good to the world
you're no good to anybody who loves you
because all you do is continue to bring
them misery and suffering why why don't
you do
everybody
one solid in your life like finally do
that one solid
and actually think about everyone but
yourself for a minute and just be done
and just end it
and so um i made the most serious i made
several i mean i've made several
attempts in my life but the most serious
attempt which i came
you know as close as you probably can
come um
uh to committing suicide and by a
miracle nothing short of a miracle i
survived i was put into a um
uh state psychiatric facility in
illinois i
there was able to spend 30 days without
drugs because i was kind of strapped to
a cot and then um as i came out of that
i
had learned some basic tools and i had
gotten a taste
of recovery and the potential of what
was there and my family was right there
to say we love you we're here to support
you and i realized that
all that illusion that my brain had been
you know tricking me into was um was
just that an illusion in that i was
going to
use these tools that i had started to
learn um and i [ __ ] up
numerous it took me a whole other
year from that point to continue to
relapse continue to disappoint myself
and others continue to like
screw up but i i got there man and um i
spent a num uh like three or four years
in chicago just
working a day job and
smoking cigarettes and writing and i
never thought i would get to act again i
never thought i would get to um
you know be creative in a professional
sense but i definitely was grateful
because i had a futon and a tv and a cat
and
um and then sure [ __ ] some friends of
mine from the old theater days saw me
working in the movie theater where i was
working at nights and were like you
gotta be we're doing this oscar wilde
player we're doing i'm starting a
theater company and
they kind of pulled me
lovingly
back to where i belonged uh which was up
on up on stage up you know memorizing
text and creating characters that's it's
where you belong it's amazing how
your mind when especially when you're on
something
can just go to one one place which is
let me do the world a favor by ending it
as opposed to
let me get
clean and be successful and
that way let's go that way but you don't
think of that way there's nothing left
you know what i mean it's
that's that's what it does it just
clouds your thoughts and just it just
depresses you even more and more
it is a miracle that you're i'm so glad
you're alive
thanks man i mean jesus
but you know animals i hear there was a
rumor that for a long time you didn't
want to associate yourself with the
character exactly is that right like you
didn't want you you thought that where
you didn't want people to think oh this
is me you're like this is just a
character i wrote and it's not me and it
took you time to really sort of say hey
this is actually is based on me
that's true i i felt like once i
started to work as an actor
that the stigma around both
you know mental illness and addiction
were going to
cloud or impede my ability to
get opportunities um which is probably
just me projecting my own still shame
that i was working through onto myself
so when we went into making animals i
said to colin
i said to mary pat who mary pat bentel
who was one of our producers on the film
i said to eve my wife and everybody else
i was like we don't need to talk about
the fact that i was an addict like i'm
here as a resource if we have any
questions but like i don't want
people to know and
they all gently would say you know
why of course
well first there we go we respect your
hand and anonymity and anybody again
who's watching or listening know that
like if you choose to get clean and
sober your anonymity is sacrosync and
you never have to tell people you don't
have to
and i didn't have to at all
what was beautiful was
the reassurance from like
eve and colin and mary pat and all my
other friends that were like we think
this movie's gonna be really powerful we
think
there's an opportunity
for you to you don't have to preach to
anybody you don't have to tell them how
to do it you have to tell them where to
go to rehab you don't have to tell them
which meeting to go to
just
seeing because at that point i would
have been
10 years 11 years clean um
just seeing that in itself is a is an
example that can inspire people and so
um we were filming a particularly
challenging every day on that movie was
so hard um and
and and a reporter from the chicago
tribune came to set to do like a set
visit and an interview about
filming in
chicago
and we went for a walk around uptown and
she said um we had a really lovely
conversation and then she said you know
where did this story come from and um i
was
you know standing on a corner of a
neighborhood in uptown where i had first
started to live when i'd gotten clean
and i kind of saw it all
come into focus
and i said
what the hell uh
[Music]
here's my story and ever since then it's
been nothing but beautiful but again
you're not required to do that i mean 13
stepping 12 stepping
however you choose to go about sharing
your message if you are you know in the
road recovery is beautiful but it's not
required you can always keep your
privacy and go to meetings you don't
have to tell anybody for me it has
become one of the great gifts
speaking
doing interviews talking about it and um
giving people hopefully just a little
glimmer of like that it can really
happen i love that i love that you're so
open about it because there are people
out there that need help that need to
hear this they have to know that they
don't have to say anything if they don't
want to and if they feel open to talk
about it to help other people they can
do whatever they want um
not to say this is funny but it kind of
amused me
is it true that in the premiere of the
movie you was sitting next to eve's dad
and there was a scene where he was
inject the character was injecting
heroin in his own penis
and uh you sat next to your wife's
father during this how uncomfortable was
that
[Laughter]
on a scale of one to ten
it was about a 450 um
and get this i was by myself so eve
colin and the rest of the team was in we
had a uh we released in like 14 cities
through oscilloscope when we came out so
the premiere in la happened the same
night as the premier new york so i was
the only person repping the film in new
york
and eve is from new york so her
incredible family who loves me so much
and they're so supportive and i'm like
god can you imagine
when i started dating eve you got to
know i was an
ex-junkie
a divorcee
an
actor uh
like
like you met and her dad and her her mom
they were both so
open to loving me and getting to know me
and i'll always be so grateful so i'm
sitting there next to her dad and we had
you know he had said you know like put
the hand on there like i'm very proud of
you i know you've been through a lot and
i'm really proud of you you know
really really glad you're but we've
never like
gotten into it you know what we're
seeing there
there's a scene where i'm jamming a
needle in my groin there's a scene where
my butt cheeks are out there's a scene
where
this guy's asking this girl if he could
come on her face i mean it is like a
rough ride oh boy
and what did he do
you know what they they they had tears
in their eyes and they gave me big hugs
when the movie was over and i was
i'll always be so grateful to eve's
family because oh my god i think that
would that would have that freaked me
out as a dad if
i came walking in the door
yeah i could just imagine her father
sitting there and just like his eyes
like no stay straight keep looking
forward
don't look at him don't look at him
don't put your hand on him you're
thinking about patting his leg like it's
okay don't do it maybe he didn't do that
i don't know let's just keep it going
let's just keep watching this film but
wow i mean i don't i i know my parents i
couldn't have done that uh my parents
sound kudos to her family
and they accept you that's the whole
part of it too is being accepted for
your flaws or whatever um
i think it's a beautiful thing look they
do they accept me and they love me and
they've never made me feel like
anything other than
and i'm not i don't fit in great with
you know i mean her dad's a golf guy and
um you know he's sports guy and he's
very you know he's he's
run
nursing homes his whole life and um
but you know what i love about them they
always try to find a common ground with
me and they always connect with me and i
i try to do the same and and they you
know they're they're my family you know
they're like
i'm just so lucky i married um i married
a woman who has such an amazing family
and i've got an amazing family too and i
i love um i love eve's relationship with
my my family as well that's great it's
rare it's rare i mean
you've done dune
ant-man
you've done all these roles
suicide squad comes up and i remember
that james gunn there was a video that
was made
uh it was where uh
him james gunn and dave dave our good
buddy dave were singing
uh a song from what set it up blue
velvet
dreams sequence from blue velvet yes
that day yes and who directed it dave
dave directed it and james played the
dennis hopper character
from blue velvet and dave played um the
um
dean stockwell character i played the
kyle mclaughlin character and
they basically dave wanted to recreate
that incredible sequence from blue
velvet and um
yes and it was amazing it's really
captivating riveting i love it i laughed
my ass off when i saw it because it's
all my friends in the video
and james says
that it's from this little video that
you did tell me if i'm wrong
but he said you had like the way you
were filmed was so unique and you had
such an incredible face
that that's where you popped in his mind
about polka dot man is that true
i believe that is true i believe that he
uh
he i i heard him say that that he was
watching me that night when we were
filming and he was like
i that's that that's it's either that's
my polka dot man or that guy has got
such a crazy look on his face that i got
to do something with with him um and uh
what a gift man what a gift like you
know it's it's it's such an interesting
thing like
i don't think i've ever talked about
work with you i don't know if i've ever
talked about work with j had ever talked
about working with james i think most of
my friends who do what we do it's like
when we get together we're either
playing games or we're talking about
politics or who knows what we're talking
about it's never like
work stuff so
you just don't think the opportu the
opportunity
to get to collaborate with your friends
which now after the last couple of years
i am
so [ __ ] committed to like
creating
stories and opportunities where me and
my friends can collaborate because it's
just i'll remember that
i'll remember i mean seriously dude me
and steve angie are like writing stuff
right now i've got
i write all the time i'm always now from
i'm committed to this because life is so
short man it's so short and i
i love what we do but i would love
i love it even more when you're getting
to like do it with people that you love
and not to say that there's not
wonderful people you meet on the journey
and you meet strangers and they become
your friends but
like how great would it be if we got to
you know
it's that's exactly right to work with
your friends is something special to be
able to hire your friends on something
is is just it's unique it's hard to be
able to do and i mean not really i mean
you could shoot things for free and just
hire your friends and keep doing it and
have fun on all different levels give me
the conversation when james called you
and uh told you you want you want to
play you texted me he texted you you
texted me i was in uh scotland um i
wrote another film with a mutual friend
of ours uh i didn't write it with her
but she starred in it um called all
creatures here below which karen gillan
um stars in yep and so i was in
scotland at the glasgow film festival
presenting the movie so we were like six
hours ahead of maybe seven hours ahead
of james
and he texted me it's kind of late for
me like 11 or 12 at night and he said i
want you
to be part of the suicide squad
and i was like because i knew he was
making the movie and i was so excited
because i i just loved the idea of james
gunn making the suicide squad and um
so then i called him right back
and
you know he was like i want you to play
polka dot man and i was like i i i you
you know this about me i'm a huge comic
nerd i've been collecting comics my
whole life and i know nothing about the
polka dot man i mean nothing about the
thrill right i was thoroughly
embarrassed because i've always
been excited at the prospect that if i
ever got like a big role in like a
superhero movie i'd be the guy that
would be like oh well which phase are we
talking about was it you know and who
which writer were we what was your
inspiration and i was like but you knew
nothing
i knew nothing and then
he sent me the script
and it was just
it was so beautiful man it was so
incredible and i um
he didn't know this about me but i have
um
vitiligo these spots can you see them on
the camera a little bit yes yep
um and
um
i
so it's kind of a white patch like white
patches right patches basically all over
my body that haunted me as a kid and
were
you know the things that we think others
are judging us by or care about you know
are so
just we're so wrong so much the time but
that that was something that really i
got i did get picked on about it and um
and i had polka dots uh spots milk
mustache i had a lot of bad nicknames
but um
i
said to him like you don't even know how
incredible this role this opportunity is
and
not to mention the fact that i have
these five and he was like i don't even
know about him he's like i've been
friends with you for
at that point
five or six years maybe he was like i
had no idea
you know what she doesn't know that i'm
talking to you she's trying to call me
say eve i'm talking to rosenbaum you
know this because i told her last night
um
i'm not saying this because
you're just with me
but i've told everybody when i see the
movie that you steal the movie entirely
i thought that your character
it was absolutely my favorite character
it was touching i
just the way you played it if you
haven't seen suicide squad your
character polka dot man
is superb it's superb the way you play
it thank you thank you yeah well i just
had to trust myself james wrote
i mean he
he created something so
beautiful in all of his care he never
underwrites a character obviously it's
james gunn he's gonna like write every
one of his characters with like 360
degrees fully you know dimensional um
but i felt such a special connection to
this and
any time i was trying to put any english
on it any time i was trying to really
you know gleam it up or anything it was
so great because he could come in and
just be like
you ain't got to do nothing
just be honest just say the lines
because i and and it's and he knew you
know i felt the way that polka dot man
has felt a lot maybe not in such extreme
ways maybe i don't have an intergalactic
virus but i do have things that i'm
ashamed of and i have felt you know
obviously depressed and um yeah so yeah
it was um
and you know what thank you for saying
that too i i just i feel like everybody
steals that movie i know there's a lot
of great characters but you're the one
that touched me the most you're the one
that i just
i immediately gravitated towards and at
the end i was just like i mean there was
a lot of great characters no doubt about
it i just your character resonated with
me it just there was something
um
you have magnetism you have that
whatever it is you're drawn to you on
screen and especially in that role um i
feel like a lot of people that's why
you're seeing the you know the the
rising your instagram numbers and all
these things because i think that you're
such a great character it's memorable
you're a mcfarland toy for god's sakes
but
um
it's yeah it's so crazy it's so crazy i
facetimed with arlo and penny they just
got back to la from new york
yesterday and i facetimed with them
earlier and the mcfarland toy and the
funko had arrived at the house
in our absence and that we had ordered
and so they were playing with them on
facetime for me showing me it was
surreal
how hard is it honestly
to work on a i don't want to say james
gun film but a movie with so much action
with so much which so much going on
like how exhausting is it on a day by
day basis it's hard it's exhausting
luckily it was such a huge ensemble
that there was definitely down time in
between like you would work really hard
for a few days on a scene and then maybe
they'd be on to some other piece or it
would be onto someone else's part of it
you know and um
but and and they were really good i mean
james plans everything so thoroughly
before you go into shooting and he works
so intimately with his a.d and his
producers so
they knew they had such a great map of
what we were doing that even though it
was so huge and so massive and so
overwhelming like every day was
10 hours we would get in there we would
work our asses off and
make discoveries and then um go i had
not done anything physically
like that before and you know there's a
scene where
thousands of gallons of water come
flooding down on us and we're trying to
swim against this massive torrent of
water there's stuff that you don't
really see where we get dropped into the
ocean um
and had to swim through like this crazy
ocean that james had built uh leave it
only james got he could build an ocean
in the middle of georgia like holy [ __ ]
dude it was so crazy um running with a
cable and trying to like jump through
the air uh like i'm leaping from
building to building like
it was crazy dude yeah
it was insane all right this is called
[ __ ] talking with dave
desmarchian das malchen okay [ __ ]
talking this is rapid fire
uh lee ann p these are my lovely patrons
they uh support the podcast in many ways
i love them and they just have quick
questions leanne p
what has been your favorite character to
portray besides polka dot man
probably jude in animals
rightfully so rozzy what's your favorite
moment of the set of suicide squad
my favorite moment on the set of suicide
squad
was
when um i had my
big i'm a superhero moment and i got
really scared and i didn't know uh if i
could get where i needed to get and all
the moving pieces were going it was a
huge day in panama there's hundreds of
crew there's
maybe a 500 extras there's idris elba
standing next to me it's like oh my god
the pressure's on and james uh who is
booming voice is coming through the
godmite which is you know reverberating
all over just like
comes to me we had this really beautiful
conversation just the two of us kind of
underneath an awning where nobody could
hear and it got me really in the most
beautiful way like where i needed to be
and then i yelled i'm a superhero i'm a
[ __ ] superhero and it was a
it was just a great moment and um
that's awesome matthew j hey david
how was working on dune been compared
how is working on doom been compared to
other projects you've worked on in the
past did you read the novels before you
got cast and thanks i love your
performances especially the one in
prisoners
oh thank you matthew i um working on
dune as with every denny villeneuve
experience is um
something that's very hard to quantify
uh it's a dream as an actor he is um an
actor's director for certain he loves
um nurturing and giving you clues and
bringing you along but also allowing you
to make discovery he's
intensely imaginative and um
i've been a fan of the frank herbert
novel for a very long time i also loved
the movie when i was a kid
and i hadn't seen it maybe when i was in
college i should say i i loved it when i
was in college and and i would get
stoned and watch doing i haven't watched
it in a long time but um
i had read dune children of dune um and
i was very excited um that one just out
of the blue fell into my
lap and when he told me he wanted me to
play piper to freeze i was so excited
and um
it was hard it was hard i will say
because the character is a mentat who is
a human who from the moment of birth has
been raised
um to basically be a human computer
computational
brain functions enhanced by the spice
that is um you know
very
data driven and and and just strictly
computing and um almost and because he's
twisted and he's been twisted by
the bad guys by the baron my character
is also like just
it's kind of like um
like a clinical sociopath computer and
um that was that was hard because it's
like emotionless
oh yeah trying to torture somebody it's
emotionless there's no like i'm getting
revenge on
right but and i'm glad you liked
prisoners i think that's a beautiful
film and again that's the movie i met
danny on and i've been so lucky that
he's now
continued to cast me in his um in his
films
raj what is the biggest i think we know
the answer well maybe what's the biggest
sacrifice you've had to make uh to
pursue an acting career
the biggest sacrifice i've had to make
to pursue an acting career um
was
um
early on i
used you sacrifice all sense of
stability and constancy and as you're
getting into recovery and mental
wellness one of the tenets of that is
building for yourself a life
that has a great deal of structure
constancy
um
consistency
um because that's a safe place to exist
when you have
you know vasculating moods when you have
a propensity towards addiction um
so i took that leap and um
and i'm really grateful i did uh it can
be hard as i told you earlier in the
conversation sometimes it's really hard
but i um i think that is it
and you you you're exercising you're
doing all these things to like
when you get depressed when you get down
you're at the last leg of this film
you force yourself to get out of bed
like you said i remember my therapist
said what are you doing in the morning i
go i lie in bed well how long do you lie
there and i'm like well i just keep
lying there and she goes do you feel
better i'm like no
what happens i get anxiety why are you
lying in the [ __ ] bed
get out of bed go do something there are
little basic things you're like you know
so now i'm like stop out you're out of
bed now now it's not you're not tired
now you're just thinking you're in your
head now it's time to get out of bed
there's certain things you do what else
do you do
yeah first thing i do right when i get
out of bed is i have this youtube
channel that i subscribe to
yoga by cassandra 10 minute daily yoga i
took the 10 minute challenge uh a long
time ago and i've been doing it ever
since i hate yoga are you kidding me i
[ __ ] hate it but
i now i love it it's been great
i love it and you meditate and uh
that's great well look dude this has
been awesome i i'm so glad you were able
to talk to me you're like how many hours
ahead of me
uh nine nine hours so what time is it
there for you nine nine pm now do you
work do you work tomorrow
i i
i might work tonight actually i just saw
a bunch of texts from the ads that i've
been ignoring um we're on overnight
you might work tonight and you're doing
this podcast
uh i might that's we're at that point
too where they're like we had to move
233 to we you know now we're doing 241
and i'm like
i hate when they do that like you're
supposed to know what 241 is or like
what c numbers are one like
is is that the one where i'm fighting
dracula is that the one where so you
have to learn
you have to pretty much learn your lines
the whole script you learn it before you
get in there so in case they switch
around
you know what was helpful for this movie
and i have i do have a good number of
lines in the in the film even though my
character is kind of a
quiet guy um working with my dialect
coach meant we were going through the
script
before we even went into production so i
was more familiar with my text than i've
been in a long time
really nice um
so when things would flip-flop and when
they would go oh you're doing that
scene where you give that [ __ ] speech
today instead of next week i'd be like
okay
okay cool
you know isn't that and my my dialect
coach they also um
they recorded
all of
my lines them saying it so whenever if i
couldn't get a hold of them or if i had
to do a scene like that i would just
skip ahead to like and listen and be
like oh that's right
debut not devil debil
or whatever
the devil said
jesus well hey man this has been awesome
real quick i guess because we i feel
like we breezed by this earlier we were
talking about gary oldman uh david very
famously had a scene with gary oldman in
the dark knight and uh i just want to
hear what that was like oh god what was
it like working with gary oldman great
interjection because david had to play
the unhinged one and gary oldman had to
be the straight man
wow um well
two stories of my so the first day i was
ever on a film set
was the dark knight in chicago i went
into hair and makeup and along the
makeup line was heath ledger getting his
joker makeup put on gary oldman
christian bale erin eckhart
me
maggie gyllenhaal and nestor carbonell
it was this really long hair and makeup
trailer i was like
so
and i met him briefly
he was super nice he had the mustache he
was you know um he was gordon um
through and through
and
then
when i was in london i got to go to
london to shoot the the second part of
my stuff which is where harvey dent you
know
tortures me and um or interrogates me
and um
gary's trailer was next to mine
and i used to smoke cigarettes and he
was smoking cigarettes at the time
so every time i'd hear him open his door
to have a smoke i would happen to just
be open i would be listening at the
window like and then the door would open
and i'd be like
oh fancy running into you again how's it
going and he was super cool super nice
very chill very um
you know
unassuming yeah
as gordon is i mean he had that energy
kind of
well and i don't know if that's how he
always works but he definitely felt you
know like
just this nice quiet midwestern guy even
though he's that's not who he is in real
life at all he's my hero he's my
favorite actor of all time there's no
doubt about it
he's a master i remember i
my friend was working at carmine's in
new york con mine's restaurant this
italian restaurant he
and he calls me
on the home phone because you know
they're wearing cell phones
and i'm living with three guys in a one
bedroom
and he says
gary oldman is here he just came in with
isabella roscellini for dinner i go i'll
be there in 20.
so i didn't have much money but i got a
taxi went across town and i waited till
they were done with dinner and when they
were done with dinner about to get the
check i just walked up and i said i just
got to tell you hi mrs russellini uh
mr homie you're my favorite actor of all
time and you know i just i really love
you and uh i just you know flew here
from kentucky from college and
you know and he's like you're an actor
and i said yeah yeah he's like
you know i've flown over kentucky a few
times
and i said oh that's great he goes
and we'll work together
we will
and he just but it was an intensity he
had that that gary old intensity gary
oldman intensity that he just looked at
me because i said i really want to work
because
we will
we will work together
and i just i'll never forget it i'm like
to this day i'm like one day i'm going
to work with gary oldman i'm going to
say hey you said we'll work together and
go yeah i don't remember that
but it's going to happen manifest it man
i mean he's the best he is the best
um favorite gary oldman you're the best
this was like this was great that i got
you
inside of me finally finally i feel like
it feels really nice
it does
toasty
yeah listen you are so engaging you're
so open you were so you're welcome to
come on anytime i love this it's a long
time coming i wish you continued success
i love your family i can't wait till
you're back please invite me to a game
night i'm double vaxxed i'd love to hang
out with you
cannot wait all right wait cannot wait
all right
say goodbye and polish it with a polish
accent
okay um this was very nice conversation
thank you very much and
bye i love you
love you man bye
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed that he got really
personal talked about his heroin
addiction which was
pretty mind-boggling how he got out of
that how he survived he's a survivor and
he works every day on himself and it
just shows it comes to show you that you
know you put the work in and you um
change your patterns and you change your
behaviors that you could
you can change
you can change for the better and he's
got a pretty great life but it's a work
in progress he's always working on
himself he says it never it's not it's
not like it's easy you have to do the
work yeah so thank you and once again if
you want to join patreon patreon.com
inside of you give to the podcast a
little more i love sending boxes and
little notes to all the top tier patrons
i love uh doing an occasional youtube
live i like doing all sorts of [ __ ] with
my patrons i love you guys
um and remember i'm going to be in
detroit the weekend of october 15th with
tom welling so we'll do a small nights
we'll do some signings and all that jazz
and uh another last shout out to my good
buddy preston christensen love the guy
um
so i just want to give a shout out to
him and here are the top patrons let's
do it cool nancy d leah s trisha sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e yukiko still
with us look at that
brian h mama lauren g nico jerry w
robert b
uh jason w apothean kristen k amelia o
allison el raj c joshua d emily s i got
to see a lot of these guys when i was in
west virginia and that was a real treat
i got to see a lot of patrons oh nice
and it was wonderful um cjp samantha m
jennifer
n mm-hmm
you're damn right i'm damn right stacy l
jan s jamal f janelle b carrie b tap the
272 not to be confused with tabitha 273.
kimberly
uh e mike e eldon sopremo 99 more
ramirez santiago m sarah f chad w leanne
p janine r maya p maddie s shannon d
melinda n kevin v james r chris h dave h
spider-man chase sheila g
brad
d correct ray h tab of the t liliana a
turd
k
turd k yeah that's michelle it's turd
it's turd something it's turd burglar
turd ferguson maybe yeah i said that
last week
yeah turd ferguson i think that's who it
is
michael s uh talia m betsy d what up
betsy claire m laura l chad l rochelle
nathan e marion meg cage in lp trav l
dan n lorraine g carrie h veronica k big
stevie w kendall t angel m rhiannon c
corey k here's the last list super sam
coleman g dev nexon michelle a liz i
is it i
yeah straight line
okay jeremy c hi jeremy andy t cody r
sebastian k gavinator n h
david c elliott m john b brandy
uh carlisle no brandy d yvore yevor
camila s bono urbano bono pena benobano
the c the c joey m willie f christina e
adelaide n jeffrey m bridget a omar i
lena n and design otg
without you guys i don't know what i
would do you save the podcast you help
the podcast by being a patron and every
patron out there that uh gives to the
podcast so thank you very much this has
been a glorious episode i loved having
dave dust mulchin on the podcast
and uh anything you want to say ryan are
you doing well i'm doing okay you're
doing okay you've been traveling a
little bit i i want to say i went to a
concert for the first time and i saw
your shirt and this this band lake
street dive i saw them at the wheel
tourney was that
the proof of vaccination required in
mass the whole time and it was wonderful
thanks for clarifying it was wonderful
they were great yeah lake street died
giving them a shout out also got just
man it was when i brought a friend who
had never heard of them before and he
was dancing the whole time so it was
really fun awesome awesome i like
hearing that good shout out uh also um
so you know if you want any sunspin
merch my band merch or want to zoom with
me go to sunspin.com
um you can get on your merch and if you
want in the inside of you merch go to
inside of you online store you can get
lex luthor stuff small but small lunch
boxes you can get all sorts of [ __ ] and
a lot of inside cool stuff tumblers
autograph stuff
thank you for listening thank you for
spending an hour of your day with ryan
and myself
that's about all i got today guys so um
you know life's good keep keep moving
keep going i had
uh
let's just say a friend had some major
problems this past week and it got
pretty dark and uh i'm glad i was there
for that friend and
but it really really
was tough on me it was tough
i don't want to get into it but i just
say
it's good to be a good friend if you got
a good friend and you see some
behavioral things and you think they're
going kind of sliding going down the
hill
talk to them
people just need someone to talk to
someone who actually sounds like they
give a [ __ ] not just like how are you
you know how people always say how are
you oh i'm good okay
next time someone says hey you doing
then
passer buys i'm going to go ah i'm all
right excuse me
that was weird
um thank you for joining us thank you
for allowing me to be inside each and
every one of you from michael rosenbaum
and brian taylor tell us up here in the
hollywood hills of california
uh
you guys much love to you we'll see you
on the flip side
[Music]